see folks I had this experience a few
years ago when I went broke doing
something that there was no possible way
it could go bad but it went bad and
there is no it broke was I borrowed
money on it I discovered that the
borrower is slave to the lender is a
real fact it doesn't say that you're
going to hell if you borrow money
it doesn't say you've sinned if you
borrow money
it just says you're gonna problems and
he goes with the territory and there's
not an exemption for farming and there's
not an exemption for business and
there's not an exemption the law of
gravity works if you're a farmer the law
gravity works if you're an airline pilot
the law gravity works if you have hair
or don't have hair the law of gravity is
just the law of gravity and the borrower
slave of the lender is a principle like
the law of gravity it 100% applies to
everyone and so for 25 plus years on the
radio I've answered the question the
exact same way I'm not likely to change
now because it's how I live my life and
I'm a weird financial person in that I
never tell you to do something with
money that I don't currently do I don't
tell you to invest in mutual funds
unless I'm investing in mutual funds I
do invest in mutual funds I you know I
don't tell you to leave your money in
the market when there's a scary thing on
the horizon and everybody's all worried
about the stock market and brexit or
Trump or whatever else you want to worry
about next week is gonna cause the stock
market to crumble Oh God the world's
coming to an end I'm staying in the
market and I'm not gonna tell you to
stay in the market and then I don't I'm
so non hypocritical that it's ridiculous
it's ridiculous how consistent I am in
my little life inconsistency with what I
teach and I don't I don't tell you to
give and then not be generous I don't
tell you to I invest and then not invest
I don't tell you to not borrow money and
then turn and borrow money there's no
secret side to the Dave Ramsey thing
it's just me it's really kind of boring
in the sense that it's so consistent
it's just freakin predictable you know I
had one program director on the radio
cake taking me off the air and he said
rim so you're gonna put somebody sleep
they're gonna run off the road and
because you say the same thing over and
over again they're gonna fall asleep
while driving their car run off the road
and wreck and they're gonna send my
radio station I think he didn't like my
show what do y'all think he's not in
radio anymore but I am so anyway I'm not
sure whether that's good or not either
but there we are we're still doing it
you know because it's just sickeningly
consistent you've got to do a written
budget I do a written budget you get we
live on the envelope system we're
multimillionaires and we live on the
envelope system why cuz that's how we're
multimillionaires we don't want to stop
doing that we got there we don't borrow
money for a car ever you know we pay
cash and send our kids to school I mean
it's just a weird idea y'all it's the
stuff we teach and we do it over and
over and over and over and over and over
and it still works why because it's the
truth and the truth does not change
depending on your generation the truth
does not change depending on what decade
it is the truth does not change
depending on the economy the only
difference is is that when things are
going really good stupid can be covered
up and all right start to feel like it's
smart but buddy when things turn south
Warren Buffett's got it right when the
tide goes out you can tell who's
skinny-dipping stupid really all your
stupid gets exposed on steroids baby
when it goes south every little I ever
know cracking your theory every little
breakdown in your way of looking at
things is gone it's over when you when
it when it turns South all the theories
are you know the negative possible
outcomes of the theories are all exposed
and you know what the downside of not
borrowing money is none I'll take that
back you might have missed out on a big
opportunity that's possible you might
have because not everything turns out
negative some things work so you might
have missed out on that but
I'll take that trade every time hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show